la parole est à monsieur pierre charon
pour le groupe ump pour six minutes
le président alain le ministre messieurs
les rapporteurs monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues il y à 12 ans vos
prédécesseurs socialistes du
gouvernement jospin mettait en place la
loi relative à la solidarité et au
renouvellement urbains
l'objectif était clair régler une fois
pour toutes les problèmes de logement en
france
il me semble que si cet objectif avait
été atteint ne serions pas en train de
discuter ce texte aujourd'hui devant le
bilan très mitigé de ce dispositif
avec maintenant plus de dix ans de recul
le bon sens devrait nous inviter à
changer sinon d'horizon au moins deux
méthodes
mais non vous persistez dans une
direction qui n'en finit plus de
démontrer son inefficacité et de
multiplier les effets pervers
cette obstination est inexplicable et
nous pouvons malheureusement d'ores et
déjà prévoir les échecs des mesures de
renforcement de la loi sru que vous
présentez aujourd'hui la première raison
est très simple et tient au principe
même de logements aidés en
subventionnant un parc locatif public
pour qu'il soit moins cher que l'offre
privée on entretient une demande qui
sera toujours supérieure à l'offre
le système engendre ainsi lui même sa
pénurie
il manquera donc éternellement des
logements sociaux
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'il y
aura évidemment toujours des candidats
pour vouloir payer leur logement moins
cher mais après tout si effectivement
ces logements étaient occupés par les
familles les plus pauvres les familles
les plus pauvres
mais là encore les bonnes intentions se
heurte à la réalité
les chiffres présentés dans le récent
rapport sur le logement
produit par l'institut de recherches
économiques
ce call indique que près de la moitié
des occupants du parc locatif aidé ne
devrait pas en profiter
en effet quand bien même ils étaient
éligibles au moment de l'attribution de
leur logement leur situation économique
a pu favorablement évolué et ils n'ont
pas quitté le logement qui leur avait
été attribué dans le même temps de
nombreuses familles très pauvres vivent
à l'étroit dans des logements privés
cette situation est malheureusement
inextricable car les bailleurs sociaux
aux besoins de ces bons payeurs pour
financer le système
et pour assurer une forme de mixité
sociale en 2007 53 mille ménages
appartenant aux foyers les plus riches
de france étaient hébergés à celle m
françois fillon avait alors d'ailleurs
saisi les préfets pour je cite améliorer
la transparence de l'attribution des
logements
vous conviendrez qu'il est assez
insupportable sur le plan moral que les
contribuables aux revenus parfois très
très modeste finances par l'impôt le
logement de familles aisées qui ont
simplement su demandé la clé d'une hlm à
la bonne personne
c'est sans doute cet embarras qui a
poussé votre collègue ministre de
l'écologie a quitté précipitamment son
logement de la rivp au mois de mai
dernier et bien au delà des problèmes
d'occupation abusives se posent ceux du
manque à gagner pour l'état
avec la cession gratuite ou presque le
terrain vacant des difficultés du coût
de gestion du parc immobilier de sa
dégradation accélérée et des problèmes
urbains que posent les projets de
logements collectifs en termes de
concentration qu'il ne s'agit pas de
répéter l'erreur des cités dortoirs
devenue cité ghetto comme sénateur et
conseiller de paris
je peux vous parler de l'exemple de la
zac des batignolles qui donne une idée
de la concentration programmée par
l'équipe delanoë en matière de logement
social
initialement prévu à 50%
ce cri déjà considérable la proportion
de logements sociaux dans le projet
global a finalement dépassé ce chiffre
pour atteindre 55%
ce n'est pas exactement l'horizon idéale
en matière de
mixité sociale autant de questions qui
devraient vous inspirer la plus grande
modestie vis-à-vis des municipalités
dont vous exigez aujourd'hui qu'elle
s'aligne sur vos chimères sous peine de
sanctions très lourdes
ce renforcement de la coercition visant
les mairies et une atteinte directe à la
démocratie locale
quel autre message est en réalité
adressée au maire si non vous n'êtes pas
assez intelligent pour inventer des
solutions plus efficaces
pourtant qui mieux que nos élus locaux
connaît les particularités de nos
territoires
les problèmes de logement ne sont
évidemment pas les mêmes à paris et à
vendôme
comme le rappelait philippe dallier tout
à l'heure et en tant que sénateur nous
avons une responsabilité particulière
vis-à-vis les territoires nous ne
pouvons admettre cette négation de la
démocratie locale
nous ne pouvons accepter les oukases
d'un gouvernement qui devant l'échec de
son idéologie l'imposent par la force
en tapant les récalcitrants au porte
monnaie
la surréglementation est en réalité le
moyen pour l'administration de reprendre
aux élus locaux le pouvoir que la
décentalisation leur avait confié en
1982 vous vous rendez compte que vous
nous fait presque regretter gaston
defferre
pour finir et c'est le plus désolant ce
texte ne créera pas un seul logement
supplémentaire en passant de 20 à 25% il
alourdit simplement la proportion du
logement social dans le parc locatif
mais le gêner aucun logement
supplémentaire pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
malheureusement devant autant de
mauvaises raisons d'aller plus loin dans
une stratégie qui montre tous les jours
son efficacité devant la précipitation
évoquée par les collègues tout au long
de l'après midi qui a conduit ce texte
devant le parlement et devant
l'amateurisme de sa préparation
nous craignons qu'une fois plus il
s'agisse d'un projet de loi politique
fonctionnant sur une idée aussi simple
que cynique plus de logements sociaux
c'est plus d'électeurs socialistes voilà
pourquoi mes chers collègues
soucieux des vrais problèmes que
connaissent les français et les
parisiens pour se loger rouge
oui sauf coup de théâtre je ne voterai
pas ce texte je vous remercie